the newest episode of the falcon in the
winter soldier brings twist
intrigue and boat fixing action as the
show hurtles toward its conclusion
and of course there's plenty of easter
eggs for the attentive fan to catch
here's what you might have missed in
episode 5. truth definitely delivers on
the surprise cameo front
while walker is talking to his wife
olivia in the courthouse after being
stripped of his captain america title a
mysterious woman played by julia
louis-dreyfus approaches the duo
she forces herself between husband and
wife and begins to talk to walker
who is she contessa valentina allegra to
fountain
i know it's hard but i don't like to
repeat myself so you can just call me
val
val has a rich history in the comics
beginning with her first appearance in
1967's strange tales number 159
she's particularly known for her close
relationship with nick fury
whom she meets while training as a
shield agent val wins fury over by
defeating him in hand-hand combat
she moves up through the ranks
eventually becoming a leader at shield
although she's dabbled in villainy over
the course of her long career
whatever her intentions are for walker
and the falcon and the winter soldier
we'll just have to wait
see we first see the raft in captain
america civil war
general thaddeus ross imprisoned some of
our favorite heroes there for going
rogue
in the comics however the raft is
generally known for housing super
villains
io mentions debucky that she'll be
taking zemo to the raft and we don't
suspect he'll lay low upon arrival
if zemo's comic's history is any
indication he might assemble the
thunderbolts while at the raft
first appearing in 1996's incredible
hulk number 449 the villainous group is
originally assembled by zemo and
disguises itself as a superhero team
although zemo has nefarious plans for
the group they ultimately end up working
as a force for good without him
later being led by hawkeye before io
takes zemo to the raft bucky asks her
for one last favor he brings a very
wakandan looking briefcase with him to
new orleans and by the end of the
episode we're still not privy to what's
inside
we think we've got a pretty good guess
though some new gear straight from what
condom
such a gift has a long history in the
comics black panther is designed to set
a wings for falcon at two points
first in 1974 is captain america number
170 and later in 2004's captain america
and the falcon number six
the first wings are detachable and fit
with many solar panels
the second set of wings are much fancier
being made of hard light
basically they're holographic their
wingspan can reach 50 feet and take on a
multitude of shapes and sizes allowing
sam
to customize the suit is needed on the
fly coming from wakanda the harness is
also fit with vibranium which can
protect sam from gunfire
they're controlled mentally through a
new helmet which also offers infrared
vision
advanced magnification and other such
abilities while we're probably not going
to see sam sport 50 foot long wings in
the next episode the wakandan's gift is
almost certainly going to be a fancy
upgrade compared to sam's previous
wingsuit
when sam revisits isaiah and baltimore
the elderly super soldier briefly
mentions his wife she died while he was
in prison and believed isaiah to be dead
the story is slightly different from the
one told in the comics
there isaiah's wife faith shabazz is
instrumental in getting him out of
prison
first appearing in 2003's truth red
white and black number one
faith marries isaiah 1940 isaiah joins
the army shortly afterward in the wake
of the pearl harbor attacks
the two conceive a child before he
leaves and vape gives birth to their
daughter sarah gale while he's away
after faith begs the government to
pardon isaiah for years isaiah is
finally released and sworn to secrecy
about his life's events
faith is also a grandmother to eli
bradley sarah's son who's appeared in
the falcon in the winter soldier
in the comics eli sometimes known as
patriots is a founding member of the
young avengers
having gained superhuman strength
through a blood transfusion from his
grandfather
considering that other young avengers
members like ant-man's daughter cassie
and wanda's twins billy and tommy have
shown up in the mcu already
it could be a sign that eli is meant for
bigger things going forward check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book heroes and villains
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you